hey guys dr. Burke here in this video I
want to talk about the key nutrients for
beautiful hair my whole concept is from
the inside out like what you put in your
body versus trying to put some cream or
serum or shampoo or condition on the
hair that doesn't really fix anything
restore because your hair is simply dead
so you want to feed it from the inside
out so here are the key nutrients zinc
very important zinc is a type of trace
mineral that is involved in enzymes to
help grow proteins so if your zinc
deficient you're gonna have hair loss
okay so that's one trace mineral and
then we have biotin there's so many
products out there right now that you
can take biotin and grow your hair back
because biotin is a B vitamin that helps
with protein it helps the growth in the
tablets of protein and but biotin also
strengthens the hair as well so it makes
the hair thicker the problem with just
taking biotin by itself without some of
the other B vitamins you can create
deficiencies of other B vitamins so you
always want to take it's not it's okay
to take biotin but just make sure you
take a beet complex together with it
okay make sure it's not synthetic now
vitamin b6 that is like the spark plug
that allows everything to kind of work
well so especially in the vault and with
protein again and the hair and not just
the hair the skin the nails the muscles
so people that are b6 deficient have
problems with protein in general and
collagen so since the hair is collagen
we want to include b6 okay and then we
have copper copper is another trace
mineral like zinc but if you're
deficient in copper you can get split
ends so the end starts splitting right
if you have split ends you know you get
a haircut but why not just use as an
indicator to see what's going on inside
so copper is a very important trace
mineral to restore that then we have
trace minerals in general you have like
94 trace minerals and trace minerals are
minerals needed in smaller amount
and they're involved in enzymes and
protein body proteins rebuilding
proteins in the body ligaments tendons
hair nails things like that silica is
another trace mineral that's really
vital in making the hair and nails
strong so it doesn't break so if your
hair is brittle you need silica and
there are supplements just for like
individual supplements that have silica
for that and then we have collagen you
need collagen because the hair is made
out of a type of protein called collagen
one problem with some people is they
don't have enough stomach acid so they
have heartburn and acid reflux and
things like that and that indicates that
you don't have enough acid later or not
and you're not gonna be able to digest
the collagen so you could literally have
a loss of collagen in your body from
your digestive system but the type of
collagen that I use I have a product
I'll put a link down below I use a wild
caught fish scale collagen because it
has unique types of collagen that are
designed to rebuild and regrow hair and
I also have all the nutrients in it with
a natural blend of B vitamins and then
the other the problem was hair loss for
example is that sometimes you get an
alopecia which is like patches of your
hair falling out or just hair loss and
general mal pattern or or hormonal
problems with your hair coming out in
the top part that is high levels of
androgens and no matter how many
nutrients you put in the body you're not
going to get your hair back because your
antigens are too high okay so what you
need to do for that is take something
that inactivates the enzyme that
converts that hormonal shift to antigen
and that would be stinging nettle root
okay that's another vital herb that I
recommend to help stop the excess
production of androgens especially in
females okay that's also in in my
product as well so anyway I wanted to
create a video on the key nutrients and
share your comments below thanks for
watching
press the subscribe button forgot the
last part and I'm gonna see you next
time am I gonna I will press up and yeah
you'll get future updates that's right
updates I knew there was a word hey if
you're enjoying my videos press the
subscribe button below and I will keep
you updated on the future events thank
you so much